you've never seen drones like this in
yesterday's drone jesting semifinals our
Lord was eliminated sudden death leaving
only standing champion eeks with over
200 wins under his belt defend his title
against your favorite up-and-coming
hothead
surrender who has maneuvered his way to
the top and record time with everything
on the line can he rise to greatness or
will this newcomer become just another
statistic meeting once again on this
hallowed ground where so many drones
have fallen the pilots ready themselves
for the match of a century Nix with his
trusty Ryder Robo foe who has been with
him since the beginning and render with
a weird elf thing what is this little
janky guy only one will fly away their
Lance's are sharp the riders are saddled
and their thumbs are steadied now there
will be drone the jousting all right the
props are speeding up and they're taken
to the skies let's see where this goes
folks both pilots are looking pretty
confident here that's a pretty good sign
the today's joust is gonna be a good one
all right now it seems like both pilots
are just trying to get a feel for each
other trying to see how this joust is
gonna shake out looks like nice is going
on the offensive right away that's
classic nice if you know anything about
his flying style surrenders doing a
great job of keeping them at bay though
he's very controlled now this is one of
surrender strong points
all right surrenders trying to keep
Meeks off of him oh that's a close pass
all right they're circling around each
other looking to make another pass
Oh Oh what is this okay and they're
still up both pilots are still in the
air you know I've never seen anything
like this we talk about it all the time
on the air never seen anything like this
looks like surrender has changed up his
tone a little bit now shifting to the
offense all right here comes another
pass and both pilots know no surrender
is still in the air that's amazing a
future man hold on hold on all right
folks this isn't looking good for nice
if he can't get his drone working quick
he's out of the joust come on his drone
is working I don't know if this is
against regulations but it looks like
surrender is going to let him fly folks
this round is not over yet looks like
we've just learned that both pilots now
have about 20% left in their batteries
they're gonna need to make a decision
soon all right nice looks like he's
going in for a hit
oh and just barely miss surrender dodges
with the skill that only he possesses
all right looks like surrenders going in
for one more attack here
there he goes and both both drones are
down
[Music]
but since surrender made the final
attack it looks like he is going to be
getting the final point making him the
new drones ousting world Jay what are
you doing but you have something to do
yeah I was I was working on that hat the
solar hat should go do it yeah yeah
don't encourage him this is easily the
craziest stunt captured on film the the
Naruto showed us he throws a knife it
just hits this guy in the head and this
guy takes a fall
[Music]
that's so me that's a pets not some
banks don't find my frames and you see
them put their hands up touch the rock
right there interacted with Butch's and
hit the water that's real dude Harvey's
face can see this you see the knees tuck
there yeah holy is real this but
the real question is who there thought
that back flipping down a cliff would
not only had he Demi he really miss it
maybe they're on wires cuz they had all
these wiring set up but even then
they're still letting them down pretty
fast unless they're splicing - that's
what I'm saying I think I think this is
splice yeah it really freaked me out
it's like this is you're basically
watching somebody almost kill themselves
and it's just so like casual in the
middle of all this even if they are on a
descender it's still going pretty damn
fast even its accelerated you know looks
like it sped up like that's a real water
splashing he wasn't going that slow yeah
yeah yeah see if we can figure down i
try to email the dudes yeah what hey
guys just go spam they're like channel
until they tell us how they're dead
before we get into making a bunch of
videos and making a mess of everything
we got to go through we got to clean up
what we left behind from last year
you're not gonna believe it
you just have someone's throwing out
super-hard
yeah is that a super tall box there's
two more like this big pile of this some
huh yeah here I got a real knife let's
just do this one bit at a time this will
be hopefully the first is like my plan
your Ren Ren it's not sure wait what why
did we get more of these we got rid of
Holly back this they sent back our
donation oh they wouldn't have done I
mean this looks like our stuff anyway I
didn't leave the address no no look at
more of these bubbles what are these
bins aren't these are the blood where we
were getting rid of all our stuff and
they decided to prank us by just sending
us more stuff no this is our stuff yeah
this isn't our stuff this is like two
more so there's two more bins in here
and another full box about our stuff
dude what no no don't even open them you
and then a whole nother box there's an
invoice here that should explain some
stuff so I'm just gonna cut this out so
much trolling on super-hard corridor
please open oh we're getting trolled
wait so either they're trolling us or
they're just like really really
innocently doing a good night no are
they gonna say guys we hope you really
can get some use of all these extra
things ever like dude you wouldn't
you're not gonna believe it
just have
Wow my mom is a portrait photographer
she was like hey you just graduated from
college we should probably take a couple
pictures oh my god this is silly can I
at least bring my airsoft guns
counteract I need a little bit of irony
in here I need a little bit of irony see
I just need a little bit of irony mom I
can't do a serious photo shoot yeah but
look at this look at this go back and
these start getting these like really
like cultured like looking portrait
photos and so so what's perfect about
these pictures is that okay so we've
been actually working with Squarespace a
little bit you probably heard some stuff
we've been we've been toying with the
idea of creating a website called Sam
Gorski calm that's all about upholding
tradition American ideals is basically
America's homepage I think I'm gonna
make it a reality right now I've been
holding under the Sam Gorsky calm domain
name for a long time with these photos
it's time to make Sam Gorski become a
reality I don't actually know how to use
this interface yes I do it doesn't look
too difficult what is this
his lifestyle and personal fashion
beauty there we go education as well oh
thanks perfect sight goals row and
engage the audience capture memories or
ideas site description America's
homepage upholding traditions of this
great country since 1986 site idleness
and torski calm whoo there you can see
this is that you look at this vibe I
already picked out here so I've already
found a great template I just need to
start getting these pictures in here
that's that's the key to success here
[Music]
all right so I think I'm done it's break
it's like right when you go to it you
know where you are saying where ski calm
you can see all the pictures here and
you just you instantly know who this
website is all about and the olders only
one section is called my principles and
when you go to my principles I have some
text here at this point in history is
more important than ever to have guiding
principles I've reached deep into the
expanses of my mind to share with you
the principles that guide me some are my
own creations some are based off the
traditions found in our great nation I'm
gonna be updating this so it's a little
thin right now but it would be updating
trust me because we have your principles
whether it's just for like a quick skim
on your lunch break or check in the
morning for some morning meditation you
know Sam Gorski calm as it all making
that was a lot easier than I thought
I'm pretty happy with the site and if
you guys are building a website you
should check out Squarespace if you go
to Squarespace comm slash Sandman eco
you can get started also we got a link
in the description where you can get a
10% discount off of anything you build
there check it out let me help you me
one of your twenty 18 goals collaborate
with an energetic DP who recently
relocated to LA from the Midwest he
comes with ideas the whole package
narrative expertise a complete camera
package he also has high action and
horror movie narrative experience that's
his passion also props for real pretty
much everything I've ever done has fed
this passion every penny earned went to
equipment and props when I left for LA I
dismantled my prop room but couldn't
part with everything and I even brought
a few pieces with me thanks Dave rocks
to you
David David can injure thank you from
the bottom of our hearts
I mean we're gonna go through every
single thing here that's actually has a
really nice best rolling some of this
stuff actually is really not this is a
really nice cop belt we have the same
gun - it's a great gun it's a great
airsoft it's just I think it's great
timing because this was the last thing I
would imagine happening
[Applause]
like look at that no let me take a
closer look here's the thing sometimes
these things are just real the other
replicas okay
these are great though for props it's
cool that it makes the noise and it
drops heat he only hangs on to the
highest quality yeah for all of y'all
who don't know how the flintlocks work
and they're actually really cool and how
simple they are piece right here is
actual Flint and this is a little plate
that the Flint scrapes against when it
drops down and in here you have your
flash pan how are your powder pan and
then there's a bore that goes into the
barrel and you drop your actual round in
here with packed with powder so that
this ignites it goes in and it combust
in here and cause this pressure to go
out the front it's really simple design
and they're really fun to to see work in
real life